In this section we're going to talk
about converting from decimals
to percents and back.
Now I want to start by saying this
is going to be very brief section.
The assumption is that you've seen this
before and this is just a reminder.
So if this is insufficient,
there's plenty of other resources online
that can help you learn how to
convert between decimals and percents.
And you can find them linked in
the instructor notes section
below this video.
So let's start with a candy bar.
That's one whole candy bar.
This is half of a candy bar.
So if you have half a candy bar,
what percent of the original
candy bar do you have left?
And you answer in this box, and you
don't need to include the percent sign.
I'll include it for you.
Don't worry if you don't know
how to do this quite yet.
We're going to review
this in the next video.
This is just to get you thinking.